35 you know the pandemic was a tough
period for all of us in a variety of
different ways and that includes our
business community small businesses in
fact they're still recovering bianca
holmen live at a new cafe that says it
is the community that keeps them going
bianca good morning
hey good morning john good morning
heather so the small business yum lab
right here it's a drive-through cafe and
they have said that they have found
various ways to stay afloat for example
even offering loyalty cars for repeat
customers now while sales have gone up
the earnings are still impacted by
inflation here in the lab they grabbed
fresh coffee smoothies bagels and bowls
owner steven zinman renovated this
building in the midst of the pandemic
and it was a battle he says the locals
they keep him off going during these
challenging times
the communities are the lifeline of
small business i value
every customer that comes through
with open arms i i just
give them the love we make our product
with love
and i can definitely attest to that i
had one of the great smoothies and it
was amazing
in my top 10 for sure so now there is a
small business resource fair put on by
the state it's tomorrow wednesday 10 a.m
taking place at the sahara west library
there'll be information about e-commerce
and experts giving tips on how to
improve your operation and guess what
the event is free so you'll definitely
want to check that out if you're
entrepreneur a new business owner again
it's the community we need to support
and rally around our small businesses
because they're our neighbors they're
our friends and of course this is small
business week so finding ways to support
your small business whether it's a
morning cup of joe or you know hitting
up your local hardware store reporting
live bianca holman live local now